trois ans presque jour pour jour après
l'évacuation de l'église saint-bernard
le mouvement des sans-papiers du mal à
mobiliser ils n'étaient que quelques
centaines à se retrouver cet après midi
à paris pour marquer cette date
anniversaire et demandé une nouvelle
fois la régularisation de toutes les
personnes en situation irrégulière louis
carzou et marie pierre cassignard ont
suivi l'un des leaders de la
coordination qui n'a toujours pas de
papiers
un refrain digne de la méthode coué
c'était bien le moins pour réconforter
cet après midi celles et ceux qui
étaient venus soutenir la cause des sans
papiers car trois ans après l'évacuation
de l'église saint bernard
il faut avoir la foi et la rage d'une
madjiguène si c'est pour être motivés
encore et toujours à la pointe de
revendications dès les premières
occupations d'églises cette pasionaria
sénégalaise responsable de la
coordination des sans-papiers n'entend
ni renoncer ni transiger la mort
tragique des deux jeunes adolescents
guinéens que c'est pas un combat dépassé
seulement justement que c'est un combat
qui concerne les relations france
afrique
les relations entre la france et surtout
les pays francophones des anciennes
colonies
c'est un combat qui dépasse très
largement la question de la
régularisation des sans papiers
mais trois ans après la brutale
intervention des forces de l'ordre pour
déloger les 220 africain réfugiés dans
l'église symbole les images comme les
colères semble s'être quelque peu
estompée
ainsi cet après midi à l'exception
d'arlette laguiller d'alain krivine les
têtes d'affiché avaient déserté le
rassemblement de paris quant aux verts
comme les nombreux collectifs tantôt
régionaux tantôt ethnique
leur présence était le plus souvent
symboliques mais qu'importe madjiguène y
croit encore
obligé de continuer comme match genk
elle que 60000 personnes se sont vues
pour l'instant refusé leurs papiers dans
le cadre des circulaires chevènement
mais ce n'est sûrement pas ce modeste
rassemblement qui va les rassurer sur
leur avenir